Mexican officials in Tijuana are
scrambling to accommodate hundreds of
Central Americans who arrived at the
us-mexico border more expected today the
group split off from a caravan of about
5,000 that's been moving through Mexico
many are escaping violence at home and
plan to request asylum here in the US
John Blackstone is along the border into
one of Mexico John good morning
good morning the San Ysidro crossing
here is the busiest border crossing in
the Western Hemisphere with about a
hundred ten thousand people crossing
into the u.s. daily yesterday US Customs
and Border Patrol closed four lanes here
to harden the border in preparation for
the migrants who have already begun
arriving where the us-mexico border
meets the Pacific cruise on the US side
Wednesday secured barbed wire atop two
fortified wall that's been in place for
decades hours earlier several people
scale defense has Border Patrol agents
watched from the other side a woman
carrying a baby managed to make it
through the fence but was quickly caught
the first wave of about 800 US asylum
seekers arrived in Tijuana by bus this
week with many setting up camp along the
wall and in shelters that are already
overflowing 34 year old Miriam Gomez
traveled from on Duras with three of her
four children why will you say you
should have asylum because I'm a single
mother and I want to give my children a
better life she says President Trump
says he's caravan there like invaders no
Hondurans are hard workers as many as
ten thousand asylum seekers are
estimated to be moving in three caravans
through Mexico traveling by foot and on
buses Roberto Hernandez arrived in
Mexico City from Honduras on Wednesday
they can put a million soldiers on the
border he says we are going to make the
attempt on Wednesday defense secretary
James Madison homeland security
secretary Kirsten Nielsen visited some
of the nearly 6,000 US troops deployed
to help secure the border I do not end
paid military personnel coming into
direct contact with migrants no one
seems to know who's paying for the buses
that brought the migrants to Tijuana but
one migrant we spoke to said he thought
it was local authorities in other
Mexican states who were anxious to move
the caravan on now because of the
backlog here it's likely to be a month
or longer before US officials can even
start processing asylum requests from
the latest arrivals gianna that is an
important point to make john thank you
for your reporting